ja ich begrüße alle teilnehmerinnen und
teilnehmer zu dieser zweiten virtuellen
sitzung des seminares und baganz
freiheitsbegriff dass ich als eine
rekonstruktion einer sehr interessanten
partie versteht die bislang noch viel zu
wenig bekannt ist teilweise sind
darunter denker die überhaupt nicht
bekannt sind und wir haben uns zum ziel
gesetzt diese weniger bekannten denker
wieder so ein bisschen ans licht zu
holen und ihnen das ein bisschen gerecht
zu werden und so schauen sind diese
texte zu recht oder zu unrecht vergessen
können wir da vielleicht nicht noch
interessante dinge lernen
und bevor wir auf diese kleineren
vermeintlich kleineren deckel zu
sprechen kommen müssen wir uns natürlich
mit dem großen denker der dann im
hintergrund steht befassen und dass es
im anerkannt und in der heutigen sitzung
steht das thema transzendentale freiheit
im zentrum
ich mache oben rechts dann im
youtube-video einen linken nein zur
vergangenen sitzung in der wir ein
überblick gegeben hatten
ich gebe noch mal ganz kurz alle fragen
dieses seminares kurz an wie lässt sich
menschliche willensfreiheit angesichts
der kausalen determination der welt
denken
inwiefern kann einem freiheits
skeptizismus argumentativ begegnet
werden worin besteht das
charakteristikum moralischer freiheit
ist eine freiheit zum bösen denkbar
und wenn ja wie genau wie ist das
subjekt der freiheit zu denken
in der heutigen sitzung geht es um die
erste frage und auch um die letzte
nämlich wie vertritt kant ein
kompatibles muss in freiheit unter dem
edition und wie lässt sich menschliche
weltweit angesichts der causa
determination der welt denken das ist
die frage nach einem kompatibel ist muss
hier kommen dann im anschluss noch auf
eine diskussion
thema so und der seminarplan dem werde
ich auch noch mal kurz an die virtuelle
tafel ohne ihn genauer zu kommentieren
nur soviel heute geht es um den ersten
text um trans en thale und praktische
freiheit und um die freiheit der willkür
ja auch heute wieder leitfragen nämlich
was versteht kein oder trans zentraler
freiheit wie ist trans zentrale freiheit
mit natur präsentiert vereinbar
das ist die frage nach dem kompatibel
ismus denen sie bestimmt schon gehört
haben die gegenwärtigen debatte was
folgt daraus
aus dieser transport ahlen freiheit und
aus dieser kompatibilität von freiheit
und natur qualität für das verständnis
des freien subjekts also uns menschen
wie verhalten sich transzendentale und
praktische freiheit zueinander
das sind zwei begriffe die kant diesen
texten die wir heute lesen einführt was
versteht kann unter willkür dieser
begriff wird heute auch im zentrum
stehen
das ist jetzt immer anerkannt dass es
ein sehr realistisches porträt von ihm
immanuel kant wird häufig sehr
idealisiert stilisiert in gemälden
dargestellt aber das ist sehr
realistisch da war kann vielleicht zu 30
jahre oder 40 aber ganz hat wie sie alle
wissen seine werke geschrieben als er
wesentlich älter waren
ja und wir werden heute ins zentrum
stellen diese kritik der reinen vernunft
aus dem jahr 1783 und wir werden daraus
genauer lesen die antinori der kritik
der reinen vernunft die ganz zentral ist
eine anthologie
kannte darunter ist ein widerstreit also
an die heißt gegen und normalos heißt
gesetz also 1 gegen gesetz eine ein
widerspruch der in der vernunft selbst
und zwar der reihe von auftritten und es
gibt verschiedene an termin bekannt drei
stück und wir lesen jetzt eben den
dritten widerstreit und dieser
widerstreit der befasst sich der dreht
sich um die frage nach der freiheit des
menschen wird und kann sieht das sehr
sehr kritisch er zeigt dass die ganzen
antinori also die widersprüche in die
sich die menschliche kleine theoretische
fünft verstrickt das ist also so die
these von kant wir sind strikt in
widersprüche wenn wir denken die diese
antinori ist durch eine these oder eine
these wie es schreibt und eine antithese
eine antithese es charakterisiert
also es geht immer so müssen nicht
vorstellen es gibt über pro und contra
also eine these und der widerspricht der
anteile und denkt unsere reine vernunft
die muss in diesem these und antithese
denken die kante eigentlich nicht heraus
aus diesen widersprüchen die sie
verstrickt ist und deswegen muss unsere
vernunft nach kant kritisiert werden das
ist die kritik trifft das heißt wir
müssen diese widersprüche die sich
unsere fans verstrickt müssen wir
auflösen natürlich auch wieder durch die
vernunft durch eine kritische wird so
die these lautet jetzt dieser dritten
angenommen
die kausalität nachgesetzt
thun ist nicht die einzige aus welcher
die erscheinung der welt insgesamt
abgeleitet werden können es ist noch
eine kausalität durch freiheit zur
erklärung derselben anzunehmen notwendig
so also hier ist jetzt ganz interessant
diese kausalität durch freiheit das ist
ein ganz zentraler begriff der immer
wieder bekannt auftritt das heißt wir
haben hier an dieser these kausalität
nach gesetzen der natur das ist die
natur kausalität der herkömmliche
determinismus ist alles ist durch das
naturgesetz kausal determiniert
ausnahmslos und diese zeit gibt es nun
ein das ist nicht das einzige sein wir
müssen noch eine zusätzliche qualität
annehmen nämlich frei heizkosten
okay das ist jetzt die these dieser
angenommen jetzt gibt es dazu aber noch
eine antithese die genau wie dagegen
steht und die besagt jetzt ist keine
freiheit in der welt sind alles
geschieht lediglich nach gesetzen der
natur also es gibt keine freiheits
kausalität dass diese position könnte
man nach der gegenwärtigen
klassifikation einen harten
determinismus nach oben rechts ein link
zu einem seminar wo wir uns mit diesem
determinismus fragen der gegenwärtigen
debatte befasst haben sodass die
antithese also die t deshalb es gibt
nicht nur natur sortiert sondern auch
noch freiheitskampf qualität als ist
freiheit möglich und die antithese zeit
nein es gibt nur determinismus so und
jetzt ist kann's kritisches denken so
geartet dass er zwischen dieser these
und der anti these vermitteln möchte er
möchte einen kritischen mittelweg
beschreiten weder die these noch die
antithese ist richtig sondern die sind
irgendwie kompatibel
aber das müssen wir jetzt genau zeigen
wie das möglich ist und das ist jetzt in
diesem dritten stück in dieser auflösung
der kurs modus
mit dem von der totalität der ableitung
der welt begebenheiten aus ihren usa
kosmologische ideen bedeute neben ideen
die die welt betreffen kosmos und das
sind also ideen die sich unsere reihen
vernunft auf drängen die sie aber in
widersprüche filmen und diese
widersprüche müssen wir markante
auflösen so und das ist jetzt diese
auflösung also diese auflösung bezweckt
dann zwischen diese these und antithese
zu vermitteln und weder der ein oder
anderen recht zu geben so ein mittelweg
anzuschlagen
und jetzt sagt kann folgendes man kann
sich nur zweierlei kausalitäten
anziehung dessen was geschieht denke
entweder nach der natur oder aus
freiheit die erste ist die verknüpfung
eines zustandes mit einem vorigen in
dessen welt worauf jena nach einer regel
folgt dann um die kausalität der
erscheinungen auf zeit bedingungen
beruht und der vorige zustand wenn er
jederzeit gewesen wäre auch keine
wirkung
die alle erst in der zeit entspringt
hervorgebracht hätte so ist die
kausalität der ursache dessen was
geschieht oder entsteht auch entstanden
und bedarf nach dem verstandes grundsatz
selbst wiederum eine ursache
ja das ist jetzt typische kann tische
formulierung also es gibt zwei arten von
qualität die hatten wir schon kennen
gelernt in dieser antinori kausalität
der natur und qualität aus freiheit ja
und jetzt muss man sich fragen irgendwie
kann die natur kausalität zusammen mit
der freiheits qualität bestehen
das ist die frage und kanten möchte
zeigen dass das geht dass wir beide
qualitäten sinnvoll zusammen denken
können deswegen dagegen sagt er verstehe
ich unter freiheit in kosmologischen
verstand gegenüber der natur gaza lädt
das vermögen einzustimmen von selbst
anzufangen dass die spontanität
was selbst anzufangen ich unterscheide
das auch noch mal hier
dass sie diesen begriff sehen
das ist die spontanität
ja
ja ein zustand von selbst aus anzufangen
das ist spontaneität deren kausalität
also nicht nach dem naturgesetze
wiederum unter einer anderen ursache
steht welches sie derzeit nach bestimmt
die freiheit ist in dieser bedeutung
eine reine transzendentalen die
letztlich nichts von der erfahrung geht
es enthält zweitens deren gegenstand
auch in keiner erfahrung stimmt so
gegeben werden kann weil es ein
allgemeines gesetz selbst der
möglichkeit alle erfahrung ist dass
alles was geschieht eine ursache mithin
auch die qualität der ursache die selbst
geschehen entstanden wiederum eine
ursache haben müssen wodurch denn das
ganze feld erfahrung soweit es sich
erstrecken markt in einem inbegriff
loser natur verwackelt wird ja also
natur qualität steht unter gegensatz zur
freiheit in kosmologischen verstanden
und das ist diese spontaneität alles
selbst eine erste ursache
hervorzubringen nicht wieder um wirkung
einer vorhergehenden ursache ist wie es
ihm in der natur nach katar falls diese
unendliche kausalkette die bis ins
unendliche zurück läuft wir müssen zu
sein aus dieser kette heraus steigen
und dieses heraus steigen dieses selbst
ursprünglich sein dass es die freiheit
in kosmologischen verstanden die man
auch die absolute spontanität nennen
könnte und diese trans en thale idee der
dieser freiheit die ist nicht empirisch
gegeben die ist nichts was wir aus der
erfahrung ab bleiben können weil der
erfahrungen die wir vor uns haben ist
alles nach dem naturgesetz strukturiert
also das ist jetzt mal erster begriff
die kosmologische freiheit
und jetzt erkannt es ist überaus
merkwürdig dass auf diese
transzendentale idee der freiheit also
diese idee der absoluten spontaneität
dass ich auf diese die der begriff der
praktische begriff derselben also der
freiheit gründe und jene also die
transzendentale idee der freiheit in
diesen der praktischen freiheit das war
eigentlich und mit geschwindigkeiten
ausmachen welche die frage über ihre
möglichkeit von jeher umgeben haben die
freiheit den praktischen verstande ist
die unabhängigkeit der willkür von der
nötigung durch antriebe der sinnlichkeit
ja jetzt haben wir hier ganz
verschiedene begriffe die auch gar nicht
so einfach sind
also es ist also wir haben hier die
trans zentrale idee der freiheit und wir
haben
die praktische idee von praktischem
verstand und die bestimmte als die
unabhängigkeit der willkür von dem nötig
um durch antriebe in der sinnlichkeit
jetzt habe ich mich beim erneuten lesen
dieses text den ich schon zig mal
gelesen habe gefragt warum spricht denn
jetzt von einer freiheit im praktischen
verstanden was ist denn jetzt sehr
praktische begriff ich glaube diese
praktische begriff hängt mit der will
kürzer sein
praktisch bedeutet ja von dem kritischen
ursprung handeln also was das handeln
anbelangt geht also um eine freiheit die
letztendlich bezogen ist auf unseren
willen es geht um willensfreiheit und
unser wille dies natürlich bezogen auf
eine handlung die transnet alle freiheit
ist noch gar nicht so sehr auf eine hand
und bezogen oder unseren willen sind die
meint nur ganz abstrakt ganz allgemein
die möglichkeit eine absolute ursache
dass sein
die praktische freiheit bezieht diese
absolute ursächlichkeit auf das
das menschliche vermögen des willens gut
auch der bilanz war das ist dann die
willkür die jetzt konkret unabhängig ist
also dass die negative freiheit
unabhängig kann man sagen das ist
negativen freilich schreibt dass die
unabhängigkeit in negative freiheit von
der nötigung durch antriebe der
sinnlichkeit antriebe der sinnlichkeit
wiederum sind nach kant letztendlich auf
die natur zurück zu führen das ist die
natur beziehungsweise natur kam sanität
also es geht praktisch darum dass wir
uns einspielen und die gekürt die vans
mausern verwenden ist nicht dasselbe
dass wir die so bestimmen dass sie nicht
der natur gesetzlichkeit unterliegt die
willkür sondern der freiheits kausalität
also müssen die sinnlichkeit die
sinnlichkeit ist einfach das empirische
asien zur triebe unsere natur in uns
dass die nicht beteiligt ist an der
bestimmung des bildes und dann haben wir
lieben die freiheit den praktischen
verstand die realisiert so viel zu
diesen sehr interessanten zitat wie ich
finde
dann gehen wir mal weiter denn eine
willkür ist ziemlich sofern sie
pathologisch klammert durch bewegung
sagt der sinnlichkeit afi ziert ist sie
heißt tierisch habe petri umbuchung wenn
sie pathologischen zitiert werden kann
ja also eine pathologische pathologisch
verstehen wir heute im sinne von
krankhaft dass man kann natürlich nicht
mehr als eine pathologische pathologisch
müssen sie jetzt so verstehen sind
leidend eine leidende eine erleiden
nämlich von außen erleiden der will
nämlich durch natur qualität das sind
diese bewegt ursache der sinnlichkeit
das ist also eine sinnliche wirkung die
durch das naturgesetz bestimmt es ein
bisschen fremd bestimmt ein metronom
willkür
daher will eine tierische ist nicht nur
effizient da müssen nämlich
unterscheiden sie ist nicht nur
effizient sondern sie ist sogar ne
zitiert also hier kann man auch nochmal
unterscheiden zwischen offizieren
existiert offiziere da gibt es bei
leibnitz die rede von inq linie das netz
existiert also inkriminiert heißt nur
genannt war unser wille unsere willkür
ist so zu verstehen dass er empfänglich
ist für reize der natur karte
durchtrieben neigungen er ist also
empfänglich er kann geneigt gemacht
werden das bedeutet in kreiert erkannt
bestimmt seien dadurch aber er ist
dadurch nicht notwendig auf eine
bestimmte option verpflichtet also man
kann sich auch anders entscheiden dass
man kann damit also unser wille ist
möglicherweise durch das naturgesetz
bestimmt aber nicht notwendigerweise es
unterliegt immer unsere entscheidung wir
bestimmt ist eine tierische hingegen
erkannt kann nur mein tier schritt nur
die natur besitzt folgen und hier
besteht keine freiheit sich gegen triebe
oder an neigungen zu entscheiden
ja soviel dazu jetzt hat kann noch was
zu der willkür sagt die die menschliche
willkür ist zwar innerhalb wie triumph
sensitiven als ein feld die neigung der
natur qualität empfänglich es vermögen
aber nicht brot um zur lieferung bei
sinnlichkeit ihre handlungen der
wirkliche handlung nicht notwendig macht
den menschen ein vermögen beiwohnt sich
unabhängig von der nötigung durch
sinnliche antrieb von selbst zu
bestimmen
hier haben wir auch einen wichtigen
begriff dieses sich selbst bestimmen das
ist schon eine art vorläufer von der
autonomie auf die wir in der nächsten
sitzung kommen werden in der bedienung
des willens die sich selbst bestimmen
kann kant spricht davon nicht in der
kritik der reinen vernunft aus der wir
die texte diskutieren sondern er spricht
über die autonomie des willens in der
gms eine grundlegung der versicherten
und der kpv vor allem aber auch noch in
der metaphysik der sitten und in der
religions- schrift und wir werden eben
im nächsten sitzung diese texte hier
noch genauer lesen um dann eben auch die
weiteren aspekte zu verstehen also
soviel dazu das ist also die menschliche
willkür oder auch der menschliche wille
der ist ein freier willen der kann zwar
bestimmt seien durch naturgesetze aber
er muss es nicht notwendigerweise es
liegt immer noch an uns wie wir uns
bestimmen lassen durch die natur oder
durch die vernunft die freiheits
qualität wie es dann weitergeht kann man
sie gleich dass wenn alle kausalität in
der simmel bloß natur wäre so würde
jeder begebenheit durch eine
andere in der zeit nach notwendig
gesetzt bestimmt seien und mithin da die
erscheinungen sofern sie die wirrköpfe
stimmen jede handlung als ihren
natürlichen erfolgten notwendig machen
müssten so würde die aufhebung der trans
en tant freiheit zugleich alle
praktische freiheit verteidigen denn
diese die praktische freiheit setzt
voraus dass obgleich etwas nicht
geschehen ist es durch habe gestehen
sollen und seine ursache in der
erscheinung also nicht so bestimmend
verhalten das nicht in unserer willkür
eine kausalität liege unabhängig von
jenen natur ursachen und selbst wieder
ihre gewalt und einfluss etwas herz
vorzubringen was in der zeit ordnung
nach empirischen gesetzen bestimmt ist
mithin eine reifen begebenheiten ganz
von selbst anzufangen das ist jetzt
wieder ein typischer satz der geht jetzt
alles ziemlich lang ich zeige ihnen mal
von wandel geht geht nämlich von hier
bis hier das ist diese grenze hat ja das
ist nicht unbedingt leicht zu verstehen
achten sie wenn sie solche texte lesen
immer auf solche signalwörter die den
text strukturieren denn das ist ja eine
ein argument aktives wort genauso auch
wenn wenn dann das sind wörter die eine
gewisse logische einen logischen
zusammenhang ausdrücken dann müsste es
immer so ein bisschen drauf achten also
fern wenn dann also wenn dann das ist
ein argument
ja ohne jetzt genauer auf das auf alle
punkte einzugehen er sagt die trans
zentrale und die praktische freiheit die
hänge mit wenn wir die trans en thale
freiheit aufheben dann haben wir auch
die praktische feiert auf die praktisch
frei die gründet in der zentralen
freiheit als sonst wäre alles nur die
natur gesetz unterworfen
ja das haben wir noch ein zitat das ist
noch mal sehr lang aber sehr sehr
wichtig einige sachen sind jetzt nicht
so wichtig die wichtigen habe ich fett
gedruckt wird erscheinungen dinge an
sich selbst wären mit den raum und zeit
formen des daseins der dinge an sich
selbst so würden die bedingungen mit den
bedingten jederzeit als glieder zu einer
und derselben reihe gehören und daraus
auch entgegen wertet im falle die anti
nomi entspringen die allen
transzendieren gemeint ist dass diese
rey unvermeidlich für den verstand zu
groß oder zu klein ausfallen müsste als
das bis daher ist erst mal wichtig als
erkannt unterscheidet jetzt zwischen
erscheinungen und den an sich
erscheinung und dinge an sich und raum
und zeit sind formen des daseins oder
auch nicht da sind jetzt also ganz
wichtige begriffe enthalten kann so viel
kann dies sagen versucht jetzt natur und
verhält kausalität miteinander zu
vereinen also kompatibel zu denken wenn
man so möchte in dem er wichtige
unterscheidung 1 führt nämlich die
unterscheidung zwischen den
erscheinungen auf der einen seite und
den dingen an sich erscheinungen sind
wie der name schon sagt nicht das
eigentliche diesel sind es sind eben
strukturen die auf dieses wesen
verweisen und raum und zeit wiederum
werden gemeinhin
so verstanden dass sie wirklich in der
welt existieren unabhängig von uns
erkenntnis objekt also die würden nach
dieser naiven sicht pikantes hat die
dinge an sich selbst betreffen die dinge
wie sie wirklich sind
wenn das so ist kann dann können wir
freiheit und natur kausalität nicht
miteinander vereinigen wenn aber raum
und zeit nicht den dingen an sich zu
gehören soll wenn sie bekannt sagt reine
anschauungs formen sind das objekt sehen
sie also zum subjekt gehören oder sich
dem subjekt verdanken
was die welt erkennt dann ist freiheit
möglich also kurz gesagt wir müssen nach
kann zwischen erscheinung und die ganz
sich unterscheiden und wir müssen weiter
raum und zeit anders auffassen als es
bisher getan wurde nämlich nicht als
etwas was in der welt unabhängig von uns
existiert sind als etwas mit dem wir die
welt überhaupt erst formen und dass wir
investieren ohne dass wir überhaupt
nicht erkennen können wenn wir diese
unterscheidung machen die die
erscheinungen und dinge an sich und raum
zeit treffen dann können wir freiheit
und natur qualität miteinander vereinen
und das ist jetzt natürlich die ganz
große frage wie das geht erst noch etwas
und es stellt sich also die frage ob es
ein richtig des junkers hat seit diesem
tief bedeutet ausschließlich entweder
oder
es gibt also keine vermittlung entweder
das oder das nur einzuleiten kannst
sagen das wird sich in die frage ob es
ein richtig dieser satz sei das eine
jede wirkung in der welt entweder aus
natur- oder ausleihen entsprechen müssen
das war die antenne sie erinnern sich an
die these und die antithese oder ob
nicht vielmehr beides in verschiedener
beziehung also die natur und die
freiheit es kann sollte beides in
verschiedene beziehen alle und der
begebenheit zugleich stattfinden können
hier haben wir ganz zentrales zitat und
das ist zu sein das was kann wenn man es
so will
wenn man davon spricht möchte kompatibel
ismus ausmacht beides in verschiedene
bezirke ein und dasselbe gleich zu
gleich stattfinden könne
dieses zugleich das ist das was ihn als
eine art und kompatible listen aus sei
natürlich eine andere form von
kompatibel ist wie wir sie die
gegenwärtige debatte kennt also hier
dieses zitat ist ganz wichtig es ist
eine frage ob es hier so ist das
qualität naturgemäß ebenfalls kassiert
entsprechen oder ob sie zugleich aber in
verschiedenen beziehung und das wiederum
das macht riskant etwas anderes als ein
gegenwärtigen kompatible listen weil er
eben nochmal unterscheiden
aber es ist möglich sich beide
qualitäten zugleich in derselben gegeben
hat als dasselbe ereignis das ist sowohl
durch naturgewalt als auch durch
freiheits kz verursacht als ich ein
beispiel ich habe hier mein smartphone
in die kamera und dieses ereignis das
ich dieses smartphone die kamera hängen
ist nach kant sowohl durch natur kasit
vollständige terminiert also bis zu
unendlichen zurückzuführen wie auch
durch meine freiheits kausalität dass
ich es wollte bis zu heben und das
zeichnet kann natürlich als ein ganz
ganz starken kompatibel ist und so
radikal kompatibles liste sind die
gegenwärtigen kompaktesten nicht weil
sie dann immer entweder den
determinismus der natur determinismus
etwas modifizieren müssen oder die
freiheit etwas herabstufen müssen und
kann denkt beides die natur kausalität
als auch die freiheit
in maximaler ausprägung und er kann sie
nur deswegen verein weil eben er sie in
verschiedene beziehungen auf dieselbe
handlung beziehen und diese verschiedene
beziehung die betreffen wie wir schon
gesehen hatten erscheinungen erinnert
sich aber auch raum und sei die
verschiedene beziehungen die betrifft
dass wir an sie betrifft das hier nur
mit diesen unterscheidung hier oben
können wir diese verschiedene beziehung
überhaupt verstehen ja so viel zu diesen
wichtigen zitat was haben wir noch ja
noch mal so eine frage nach kompatibles
muss lese ich auch noch vor es ist also
nur die frage ob dem ungeachtet in
anziehung eben derselben wirkung die
nach der natur bestimmt ist auch
freiheit stattfinden können oder diese
durch jene und verletzliche regel völlig
ausgeschlossen sein
ja also wieder in ein zelt beziehung der
cebit wirkung die natur bestimmt ist
auch freiheit statt winkel das ist die
frage nach der vereinbarkeit von natur
und freiheits qualität oder ob es völlig
ausgeschlossen sei und dieses völlig
ausgeschlossen sei
das könnte man nach heutiger auffassung
eine inkompatibel ist muss nennen
man muss immer ein bisschen aufpassen
mit der moderne begrifflichkeit aber das
hier wäre letztendlich dann die these
dass es eben nicht vereinbar ist
naturkost und freiheits karte also
völlig ausgeschlossen
ok diese these vertritt kann nicht er
sagt sie sind vereinbart und hier zeigt
sich zwar die zwar gemeinde aber
betrübliche voraussetzungen der
absoluten realität erscheinung zugleich
ihren nachteiligen einfluss tiefe zu
verwirren und jetzt kommt wieder ein
zentraler zitat denn sind erscheinungen
dinge an sich selbst so ist die freiheit
nicht zu retten als dann ist natur die
vollständige und an sich hinreichend
stimme die ursache jeder begebenheit und
die bedingung derselben sie derzeit nur
in der reihe erscheinen enthalten die
samt ihrer wirkung unter dem
naturgesetze notwendig sind wenn dagegen
erscheinungen für nichts mehr gelten als
sie in der tat sind nämlich nicht für
dinge an sich soll bloße vorstellung die
nach empirischen gesetz zusammenhängen
so müssen sie selbst noch gründe haben
die nicht erscheinen sind also hier
sehen wir wieder diese transzendentale
unterscheidungen ident sind erscheinen
es ist das freilich zeiten das ist der
zentrale satz hier wir müssen an sind
nach kant erscheinungen und dinge an
sich selbst als die dinge wie sie
wirklich sind unterschreiben
erst wenn wir dazwischen unterscheiden
dann können wir freiheit dritten und
frei treten bedeutet eben natürlich auch
verkannt freiheit und natur kausalität
zusammen zu denken das ist diese
unterscheidung die kannten führt diese
transplantate unterscheidung zusammen
mit trauma zeit als client anschauungs
form die uns erst fällt dann denkt
möglich machen lässt wichtiger sei eine
solche die ursache aber würden an ziehe
um ihre qualität nicht durch erscheinung
bestimmt ob zwar ihre wirkungen
erscheinen und sie durch andere schaden
bestimmt werden können
sie ist also samt ihrer kausalität außer
der reihe den atomkonsens at dagegen
ihre willkommen in 3d empirischen
bedingungen angetroffen wer die wirkung
kann also in anziehung ihre integrierten
ursache der freiheits qualität als frei
und doch zugleich in anziehung der
erscheinungen der tour kann sie als
erfolg aus den sieben nach der
notwendigkeit der natur angesehen werden
wir können halt und dasselbe ereignis
wie ich schon vorhin zweite die
smartphone hochheben das können wir
sowohl als ein ereignis von freiheits
kausalität als auch als ereignis aus
natur kann man sehen
eine unterscheidung die wählen sie im
allgemeinen und ganz abstrakt betrachtet
vorgetragen wird äußerst subtil und
dunkel erscheinen muss die sich aber in
der anwendung
aufklären wird ja das ist also dieser
kerngedanke verkannt die wirkung also zb
das smartphone hochheben man kann auch
hier sagen ein ereignis
ja ich schreibe es am besten mal mit
stift in einem ereignis das wir ist ein
ereignis ganz willkommen ein ereignis
kann sowohl als durch freiheit bewirbt
angesehen wird als auch dasselbe
ereignis als produkt der natur qualität
und das macht natürlich riskant einen
kompatibel ist aber eine sehr spezielle
kompatibel ist in weiter eben sagen dass
das hier für eine unterscheidung ankommt
die wir schon gesehen hatten die sehr
schwer zu verstehen ist die nicht dem
tradition realistischen weltbild
entspricht der frauen zeit unabhängig
von uns existieren und eine auffassung
die wie kanzler ist dann wirklich
verständlich wird wenn wir die anwendung
dieser theorie dann betreiben und die
anwendung ist jetzt in meiner ansicht
der bezug diese unterscheidung auf unser
handeln konkreten auf den menschlichen
willen und diese anwendung die nimmt
kann vor in seiner kritik der
praktischen vernunft die wir der
nächsten sitzung behandelt werden
also unerkannt antizipiert schon die das
stirnrunzeln seiner leser sagt dass es
eine sehr sehr schwierige unterscheidung
hier habe ich erkannt wo die anmerkung
machen wollen dass da der durchgänge
zusammenhang alle erscheinung
einem kontext natur ein und nachlass
liches gesetzt ist dieses alle freiheit
notwendig um stützen müsste wenn man der
realität erscheinung hartnäckig anhängen
wollte daher auch diejenigen welche
rinde gemeinmachen folgen niemals dahin
haben gelangen könnten natur und
freiheit miteinander zu vereinigen
hier haben wir wieder begriffliche
wendungen die auf allen kompatibel ismus
hindeuten es geht um eine einigung
die frage stellt sich jetzt nur wie
werden natur freiheit vereinigt auf
welcher ebene werden sie vereint oder
durch welche anderen die wir noch
treffen müssen können sie erst
verhandelt werden und hierdurch diese
annahmen getroffen und müssen da
unterscheidet sich kann eben ganz
ausdrücklich von kompatibel ist in der
gegenwärtigen vor allem analytischen
debatte